I know this is not how you wanted to
spend your weekend but guess what
me neither she was supposed to see her
boyfriend ever he's not my boyfriend
then why did he make you a playlist
there was sex off oh my god shut up mom
Oh playlist you grew up here why are you
selling it that's what you do when
someone passes away check it out
fully automated security system windows
have retracted lead shields this place
is a fortress I guess some people get
paranoid in their old age what were you
trying to hide dad I just want to say
again how sorry I was to hear about your
father just let me make it through the
weekend and come home mom I swear to God
if your eyes
[Music]
[Music]
I want you to listen you are a woman
below at the mercy of strangers what do
you want we want something in the house
I will do anything to protect market
know exactly what I say or you and your
kids will not survive this night yeah
she's gone
find her she took out the lights she's
smart but we have her kids now she's
desperate I'm just a mom you have no
clue what I'm capable of
she's in the house
this isn't gonna work you're done
I lived with a bad end
[Music]
you notice we broke into the wrong house
breaking news a star-studded event at
the level Hotel in Los Angeles has been
taken over by armed gunmen we now go to
a live feed from the assailants and can
confirm that one of the hostages is
international pop star shaggy
yeah you know killing is happening
payable to me sing it shaggy
honey came in and she caught me
red-handed creeping with a girl next
door picture this we were both
butt-naked and you know testing for how
do i four kits that I have given a extra
key
[Music]
we have three waiters on the run I think
we should turn ourselves in
what's with the pockets I'm showing them
I'm unarmed we can take them my name is
Alex but three exes I want to go
explosive on these [ __ ] 3x
means poison by the way it's also a Vin
Diesel movie
let's [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
Swatt new seals transporters
[Applause]
what are you doing up there oh thank god
the hell are you doing they're here to
help us we're not gonna look cool is
[ __ ] getting saved by the LAPD do you
even listen to Kendrick Lamar loves me I
can't believe I followed a loser like
you around for years
guys stop you just shot at me I shot
near you [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I propose we call a doctor
all the best doctors are dead I can't
remember it was a life ago isn't this
Comrade Stalin not secret enemy I need
to stop reading together the plan
how could you were unemployed at the
same time it's darkness
[Music]
everything's gonna be fine it's not
exactly fine is it my father I know with
his head open Stalin would have wanted
the committee as alone all those in
favor
Terry you animus Lee
ruched not first not first would you
stop with this I want to make a speech
at my father's funeral no no problem
I think oh yes but practically when I
said no problem what I meant was no
problem ignore me mostly but I am very
furious you're the good guy now you
locked up half the nation
yes I'm not releasing them
what
I've been picking out funeral cushions
with slim Hitler over there
trust no one
darling will be nothingness
don't worry nobody's gonna get killed I
promise you
[Music]
I've had lightness that made no sense
unless
[Music]
I will not be silent I just have one
question
when cap needed help if I'd asked you
would you have come I guess we'll never
know but if you had you'd have never
been caught
[Music]
I do some dumb things and the people I
love the most they pay the price thanks
to you we had to run
we're still running let's go
[Music]
maybe you just need someone watching
back
link to partner
hold on you gave her wings and blasters
so I take it you didn't have that tech
available for me no I did
I thought I'd own that again I think I'm
going mad sorry your father's gone at
some point we have to face up to who we
are who were meant to be I think I know
where my dad went that's right in the
middle of the devil sea it would be an
adventure death isn't an adventure
[Music]
what are you doing here Laura seven
years I've been on this island your
father they put me here now I see the
likeness intelligence some recklessness
what do you know about my father
[Music]
Laura there was more to my life than
boardrooms and business deals there's an
organization called Trinity it's looking
to start a global genocide you dad soon
you had a bigger holiday got a knack for
the unexpected
you must stop for Laura promise me
[Music]
ladies first open the tune
[Music]
put it down your finger.this pulling
this trigger you messed with the wrong
family
[Music]
honey mama what is it I have to go with
Roy
I was told to take a mental hotel
[Music]
I said that he was an enemy of the state
take off your dress
and in exchange my mother look at the
doctor she need him instead they cut his
throat
there could be no witnesses so they gave
me a choice die or become a sparrow from
this day forward you will become spells
weapons in a global struggle for power
you'll be trained in psychological
manipulation we must learn to push
yourself beyond all limitation take off
your clothes when we are finished with
you the person you were will no longer
exist every human being is a puzzle of
need you must become the missing piece
and they will tell you anything you have
a gift you know how to survive this is
what you were meant to do
there is a traitor in the government his
last known contact is an American dead
Klassen a very same pool yesterday are
we going to become friends so what you
want
it's a sparrow the only matter cuz of
what you could do for them work with me
and make these men pay
you are better this than any of us your
only problem is you have a soul
we can't trust a word that comes out of
her mouth there's something else
Auri now seeing
the fees compromised she will be
eliminated
what have you done
you belong to them they will never let
go
I'll find a way
tell me if this sounds familiar
a man walks into a store he searches for
a certain section of books he takes out
a can of lighter fluid I know why he
burned the books why because he wrote
Sydney Hall one of the best Friday short
time I've been searching for him for
years under his nose is sittings one of
our brightest students because brilliant
what if I wrote enough what would it be
about it's your name melody no no no
wait why do you keep burning away from
me because it's fun
[Music]
you've been number one on the bestseller
list for eight months I'm seeing face
things that aren't there
[Music]
really one all right so and it's gonna
shake people up you should get off be
sure to take me with you she write about
me you know my father is this is me I
should write a book about him you'll be
singing a different tune tomorrow what
happens tomorrow this book is a
dangerous sign of the times
burnings I apologize for nothing
we're being food I don't know what he
wants he knows everything about me no
one is claimed to see or hear from
Sydney Hong over five years now how is
that possible everywhere I go he's with
me you were the last people to see him
alive that's not a beginning to a great
book I don't know what is
the entire course of a person's life can
change in a millisecond
this has to end Sydney
business person I somebody you think
give me the information about Sydney
Hall
and we'll never sing again
[Music]
where is my daughter
people whom just disappear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you have been nothing but a positive
force in my life
she's one happy birthday be it's a dream
come it's amazing
let's get away from the city it's miles
away from everything
it's a celebration I'm trying to create
a moment I want to give us something she
could remember for a rest my life built
in myself I learned that the prison
autoshop sweet ride
smoked a piece in the story of all
Claire I'm not looking for any trouble
trouble can't hold a play conversation
get your minute what are you doing in
here what's going now they've got a big
problem can't find the phone people I
work for do not accept mistakes it's
crazy
hey baby your phone is ringing hey girl
something in my gut was telling me that
she needed help I think I put my phone
in your bag by accident let me help you
just give me the phone
just give me the phone okay hey you go
something
I need help right now please I don't
know where I'm at where are you lady
I keep you just for me just for me
I will find you
are you aware that olivia is in love
with your boyfriend
well she's not we stop Penelope
damn make a little Livia let's get this
party started type garnet truth what are
your intentions with our sweet Olivia I
needed to find someone with friends that
I could trick into coming here I could
tell Olivia was a music argot I brought
you all up here cuz I'm okay with
strangers dying if it means I get to
live what the hell
games will okay wherever you go whatever
you do it'll find you okay yeah
something really weird has been going on
ever since Mexico oh come on I'm seeing
things truth all right there dear I know
it sounds insane
just something this fine young lady here
dared me to show you my business Carter
said tell the truth or you die do the
dare or you die refuse the plane you
don't screw this you die
[Music]
we're not playing the game it's playing
us so what do we do only choose truth
[Music]
wait I'm sorry touch me again and I'll
break that hand truth that's not how
this works the only game decides break
Olivia's hand you have to do it because
pissed as I am at you right now there's
no way I'm gonna break your hand you
don't really have a choice
God just do it this game is too smart
half the people in this photo are now
dead we need to find the left start at
all this
how do we get out of this game alive
you can't it's only ends when all the
players are dead maybe a trans next dare
me to choose but for one of you to kill
truth or dare
[Music]